مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استاهل هذه ابرز
العناوين
[موسيقى]
قبل جوله الاعاده باسبوعين وبورقتي
الاكراد واللاجئين سنان اوغان يرسل شروط
دعمه لاردوغان او كلتش
قطاع النص في السودان يؤكد سيطره قوات
الدعم السريع على مصفاه الخرطوم ويتهمها
بتعطيل التوزيع
زيلينسكي يختتم جولته الاوروبيه بحصيره
مساعدات ضخمه بينها صواريخ ودبابات
ومسيرات هجوميه
بعد اخراجه عن عمران خان انصار الحكومه
الباكستانيه يطالبون باستقاله رئيس
المحكمه العليا
[موسيقى]
من الخاسر الوحيد في الانتخابات الى
الحصان الاسود والمتحكم فيها وبمصيرها هذا
ما تحول اليه سنان اوغان بعدما فرط
الشروطه لدعم احد المرشحين المتاهلين
لجوله الاعاده بنهايه مايو الجاري المرشح
الخاسر والمتعصب القومي كاره الاجانب
والمعادله للاكراد كما يوصف في تركيا
اشترط على كلتش دار اوغلو وقف دعم الحزب
المؤيد للاكراد فيما اشترط سنان على
اردوغان ان يرحل اللاجئين السوريين مقابل
دعم انصاره له بجوله الاعاده بانتظار من
سيلبي طلب الخاسر الوحيد التي تعود اصوله
الى اذربيجان
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان الانتخابات تتجه نحو اجراء جوله
ثانيه ومن سيحسمهاهم القومي من الاتراك
واتباع كمال اتاتورك ايها الاصدقاء
الاعزاء امامنا 15 يوما اضافيه صعبه وخلال
هذه الفتره وفي حال انتهت الانتخابات
بالنتائج الحاليه وذهبنا الى جوله ثانيه
فسوف نبذل قصار جهودنا لجعل هذه العمليه
الانتخابيه مفيده لامه وبلادنا وفي هذه
الاثناء لا نقول اننا سوف ندعم طرفا دون
سواه
هذا ونشر كمال كالجدار اوغلو مقطع فيديو
على حسابه في تويتر قائلا فيه انه سيقاتل
حتى النهايه على حد وصفه
[موسيقى]
لترجيح كفه اردوغان او كليتش دارولو
800 الف صوت بنسبه خمسه.2%
على اردوغان اعاده اللاجئين وبقائهم خط
احمر بالنسبه لنا
دعم كريستيانو مرهون بعدم تقديمه تنازلات
للاكراد
القوميون الاتراك والاتاتوكيون ستكون لهم
كلمه حاسمه في جوله الاعاده
سنتشاور مع قاعده ناخبين قبل التوصل لقرار
حول جوله الاعاده
للمدن الكبرى كلمه الفصل بتحديد هويه
الرئيس الحاكم للبلاد وهذا ما حصل فعلا في
تركيا فغيرت التصويت في المدن الكبرى
نتائج وقلب موازين القوى كما ادخل البلاد
في جوله رئاسيه ثانيه بين الحزب الحاكم
وتحالف المعارضه الخريطه هنا توضح
مشاهدينا ان المنافسه احتدمت بين
اردوغانو في مدينتي انقره التي لها طبعا
دلالات رمزيه على النظام المتبع في البلاد
واسطنبول التي تعتبر قلب تركيا الاقتصاديه
النابض فالعاصمه انقره انقلبت على الرئيس
الحالي وتفوق فيها اوغلو باكثر من 47%
مقابل 46% لاردوغان اسطنبول بدورها اعطت
ايضا الغلبه للمعارضه بنسبه تفوق الثمانيه
والاربعين بالمئه في وقت حصل فيها اردوغان
على نسبه يزيد عن 46% كما نشاهد هنا مما
ادى الى تراجعه الى مدون الخمسين نقطه اما
المفاجاه الكبرى فكانت في مناطق الزلزال
وهي احدى عشره ولايه ابرزها كما هو معلوم
غازي عن تاب واضن وحطائي التي تعتبر معاقل
المعارضه تقدم فيها اردوغان بشكل كبير
امام غريمه حيث صوتت مدينه هاتايلي
اردوغان باربعين او 48% مقابل
48% فصل سبعه لكي تشدار اوغلو اي بفارق
300 صوت فقط كما نشاهد هنا بالنتائج بين
الفريقين
ابرز
التحاليل
تحالف الجمهور
322 مقعدا تتوزع على حزب العداله والتنميه
ب 267 مقعدا
حزب الحركه القوميه 50 مقعدا
حزب الرفاه الجديد خمسه مقاعد
الاتحاد الكبير بدون مقاعد
تحالف الامه 213 مقعدا
تتوزع على حزب الشعب الجمهوري ب 169 مقعدا
حزب الجيد باربعه واربعين مقعدا
تحالف العمل والحريه 65 مقعدا
تتوزع على حزب اليسار الاخضر بواحد وستين
مقعدا وحزب العمال باربعه مقاعد
مشاهدينا لنقل الصوره من تركيا ينضم الينا
من اسطنبول مفرد العربيه طاهر بركه ومن
انقره مراسل العربيه زيدان زنكلو سابدا
معك طاهر طاهر يعني هي المره الاولى التي
تذهب فيها تركيا الى جوله اعاده كيف هو
نبض الشارع للذهاب الى جوله اعاده خصوصا
ان المعلوم يعني بهكذا نوع من الانتخابات
تقل الحماسه نسبيا بالدورات الثانيه كيف
هي الصوره من تركيا
اعتقد ليالي ان حجم الاستقطاب ازداد الان
لانه الموضوع انحسر بين رجلين وشخصيتين
وتوجهين هو كان بالاصل كذلك ولكن زاد
الامر الان حماسه عند الناس لايصال مرشحهم
لانه لا اردوغان استطاع ان يتجاوز الخمسين
بالمئه ولا الطرف الاخر
رغم النسبه الاكبر التي حصل عليها اردوغان
طيله اليوم ونحن نتنقل من منطقه الى منطقه
في اسطنبول ونستمع الى الناس وما الذي
يقولونه من مختلف الفئات العمريه والشرائح
في مناطق تعتبر معاقل لحزب العداله
والتنميه
او معاقل لحزب الشعب الجمهوري كذلك يمكن
ان تلحظي الفرق في الخطاب وفي التوقعات
وفي خيبه الامل بطبيعه الحال يعني الكل
يقول اليوم بان كليتش دار اوغلو كان لديه
فرصه بالامس لكي يعبر
انه خسرها ولن يتمكن من فعلها في الجوله
الثانيه حتى انصاروا يقولون ذلك ولكن كل
ذلك مرهون بالتحالفات التي سنشهد عليها في
الاسبوعين المقبلين ولو انه الارقام اذا
ما تحدثنا عنها قد لا تخدمه كثيرا الا ان
حماسه الشارع ونبضه بدون شك الان اكثر من
اي وقت مضى لانه الانتقال الى جوله ثانيه
تعني يعني عدم حسم الامور وبالتالي هذا
سيحمس الناس اكثر لاما يبقوا على
الاستقرار ولا يغيروا او يختاروا تغيير في
المره المقبله في الجوله الاعاده ولو بعد
ذلك صعبا للغايه حتى الان طاهر اسمح لي ان
انتقل الى انقره والزميل زيدان زنكلو لنقل
الصوره ايضا من هناك زيدان يعني على ابواب
الجوله الثانيه كيف هي صوره من انقره طبعا
يعني النتائج لم تكن مف اجئه من انقره
الصوره معك لو سمحت
نعم حقيقه يعني يوم امس كنا في معقل حزب
العداله والتنميه في انقره والزملاء
الاخرين الذين كانوا يشاركون في التغطيه
كانوا في
مقر حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعارض الذي
يقوده كما
حقيقه الصوره كانت مختلفه تماما حاله
الفرح التي كانت في
معسكر او في مقر حزب العداله والتنميه كان
هناك حاله معاكسه تماما حاله من الهجوم
وبعض الغضب من كوادر حزب الشعب الجمهوري
لاسيما ان الانتخابات البرلمانيه على وجه
التحديد كانت مفاجئه لم يستطيعوا التقدم
في البرلمان رغم تراجع تحالف الشعب لكنه
بقي مسيطرا على البرلمان هذا سيعطي افضليه
للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في جوله
لاعاده كون هناك توقعات كثيره تشير الى ان
الشارع التركي ربما لن يفضل
يكون هناك تعارض ما بين الاداره التنفيذيه
ممثله برئيس الجمهوريه وبين الاداره
التشريعيه مماثله بالبرلمان باعتبار ان
البرلمان بات بيد تحالف الشعب هذا يعطي
افضليه للرئيس التركي منعا للدخول بمشكلات
اكبر في حال وصل زعيم المعارضه الى
منصب الرئيس منصب الرئيس هذه النقطه حقيقه
تخيف كثيرا
المسؤولي حزب الشعب الجمهوري وكوادر حزب
الشعب الجمهوري نتيجه الانتخابات كانت
مفاجئه لهم مصادمه جدا حقيقه ربما هي
نتائج استطلاعات الراي ومراكز الدراسات هي
التي اعطت هذه الثقه لمعسكر المعارضه بان
النصر سيكون كبير وحتى في كل الخطابات
التي التي كانت
والتجمعات الجماهيريه سواء كان اكرم امام
اوبلو او حتى كمالك الجدار اوغلو زعيم
المعاضل المرشح او منصور
تحالف طاوله سداسيه كانوا ينادون كمال
تجار اغلب الرئيس الثالث عشر كان هناك ثقه
كامله بالنصر لذلك بقدر ما كانت هذه الثقه
مرتفعه والامان مرتفعه حاله الاحباط
جاءت بشكل كبير ايضا جاءت مرتفعه نتيجه
النتائج طبعا لا احد في الشارع التركي
يريد يعني لا احد كان يفضل ان يذهب الى
جوله ثانيه لكن الامور الان هل ينعكس
اليوم على يعني الذهاب الى
الاقتراع بالدوره الثانيه خصوصا يعني وان
المدن الكبرى اليوم اعادت تثبيت انها تدعم
الشخصيات السياسيه المعارضه على حساب
التقليديه ولكن النتائج كما ذكرت بمجلس
النواب هي مغايره طبعا
نعم لا شك فيما يخص المدن الكبرى انقره
واسطنبول صوتت او ارادت ان توجه رساله
للرئيس التركي رساله تذمر من الوضع
الاقتصادي وبالتالي هذه المدن تحديدا انقر
واسطنبوليا اكثر المدن التي تعاني من
التضخم وغلاء المعيشه وبالتالي
الناخبون هنا صوتوا يعني الذين صوتوا لحزب
الشعب الجمهوري واوزعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري نتيجه الوضع الاقتصادي اكثر مما
صوت نتيجه الايديولوجيا اما بقيه المناطق
التي صوتت للرئيس التركي في ارض والمناطق
مناطق الزلزال صوتوا على ما اعتقد يعني من
خلال متابعاتنا خلال الفتره الماضيه لوعود
الرئيس رجب اردوغان في مناطق الزلزال والى
تاريخ هذا الرجل وايضا الايديولوجيه في
تلك المناطق لعبت دورا اساسيا في مناطق
البحر الاسود ووسط الاناضول لا يريدون
التغيير هناك الايديولوجيهي التي تحكم
مزاج النافو وبالتالي الناخب اعطى صوت
اعطوا الاصوات للرئيس التركي اردوغان لا
شك ان الجوله الثانيه ستشهد اقبال كثيف
نعم كما ذكر
الموضوعات في الشارع
اسمح لي زيدان ان اعود الى الزميل طاهر
بما اننا يعني اصبح الوقت ضيق طاهر ايضا
ساتطرق لنفس النقطه اليوم اثبتت المدن
الكبرى ثبتت يعني ما ما حصل بالانتخابات
البلديه وهي الميل الى الشخصيات المعارضه
على حساب اردوغان وهي طبعا رساله سياسيه
هذا هو عكس الانتخابات النيابيه والاصوات
بالانتخابات النيابيه ماذا يعني ذلك اليوم
لشارع اسطنبول
بدون شك يعني هذه نقطه مهمه وتثير الاعلام
الدولي فيما يتعلق بهذه
النتائج التي تم تحقيقها ولكن يجب ان نشير
ايضا الى الفارق في هذه النتائج ليس كبيرا
لا نتحدث عن فوارق حاسمه او يعني مفصليه
يعني اذا ما تحدثنا عن اسطنبول في نتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه هذه مقابل
48.6 بالمئه
نحن نتحدث عن 46.7 بالمئه لاردوغان في
انقره 47,3% لكم مقابل 46% لاردوغان
ازمير طبعا الغلبه فيها بطبيعه الحال لكم
هذه لها رمزياتها لاننا نتحدث عن اسطنبول
وانقره ولكن بالنتيجه الانتخابات حساباتها
مختلفه والتغيير يبدو ليس ح في 2019 خسر
حزب العداله والتنميه رئاسه البلديتين في
اسطنبول وانقره نعم ومن ثم انتظرنا كل هذه
السنوات في 2023 حتى ربح حزب العداله
والتنميه بتحالفاته في البرلمان وحصل على
نسبه اعلى بكثير في الرئاسيات في الجوله
الاولى على الاقل ولكن يعني حصل عليها
ويعني فاذا التغيير حتى لو كانت الارقام
ارقام حزب الشعب الجمهوري او تحالف الامه
اعلى بقليل في هذه المدن المهمه الرمزيا
بشكل كبير الا ان حسبه الانتخابات
بالنتيجه يعني رقم زائد رقم يساوي
المعادله كامله من يربح ومن يفوز في
السلطه هل سنشهد تغييرات في 2024 في
الانتخابات البلديه هل سيتمكن الرئيس
الحالي من استعادتهما كما يتوعد ويعد
مواطنون مواطنينه ام ان تغيير
الاموال على قدم وثاق من قبل المعارضه من
الان حتى الانتخابات البلديه شكرا لك شكرا
لكما مراسلي العربيه طاهر بركي موفد
العربيه الى اسطنبول
والزميل مراسل العربيه زيدان زنكلو مع
انقره
ابرز مقاعد البرلمان التركي حزب العداله
والتنميه عام 2018 حازم 295 مقعدا عام
2023 تراجع الى 267 مقعده
حزب الشعب الجمهوري عام 2018 حيث 146
مقعده عام 2023 زادت حصته الى 169 مقعده
حزب الحركه القوميه عام 2018 حازت 49
مقعدا عام 2023 حاز 50 مقعده الحزب الجيد
عام 2018 حاز 43 مقعده عام 2023 حاز 44
مقعدا حزب اليسار الاخضر عام 2018 حاسس 67
مقعدا عام 2023 تراجع الى 61 مقعدا
عن حاسم ان يفصلان اردوغان وك اوغلو عن
جوله ختاميه تقرر من سيحكم تركيا للفتره
المقبله في جوله انتخابات رئاسيه ثانيه
تعد الاولى في تاريخ تركيا التي تتزامن
طبعا ويتزامن اجراؤها مع الذكرى المئه
لتاسيس البلاد كجمهوريه عقب انهيار
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه نسبه المشاركه
مشاهدينا كانت قياسيه وغير مسبوقه وصلت
الى
89% ولكن ما الذي سيفعله اردوغان خلال
هذين الاسبوعين لاقناع الناخبين بضروره
استمراره رئيسا للبلاد اولا يواجه الرجل
اي اردوغان صعوبات وتحديات لجذب كتله
ناخبه جديده تحسم المنافسه لصالحه لان
اولويه ان ناخذ التركيه اليوم هي مواجهه
الصعوبات الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه التي فشلت
فيها سياسات اردوغان الغير معهوده
اقتصاديا وهنا يراهن اردوغان شعبيته بين
الناخبين الريفيين والطبقه العامله
والمتدينين الذين ينسبون اليه الفضل
بتطوير البلاد وتعزيز مكانتها الدوليه
خلال العشرين سنه الماضيه ايضا سيعمل
اردوغان على استقطاب اصوات مناصري المرشح
الثالث وهو سنان اوغان الحاصل بحسب
النتائج الاوليه للانتخابات على 5% من
الاصوات بحسب طبعا النتائج الرسميه حيث من
المرجح ان يفضله اتباع اوجان القوميين
اليمينيين تقول هنا صحيفه نيويورك تايتس
هذا كان عن اردوغان ولكن ماذا عن اوغلو
اوغلو هو مرشح المعارضه سيستغل نقاط ضعف
خصمه اردوغان لكسب اصوات مناصريه
والمترددين ايضا كما سيعمل زعيم المعارضه
لتعزيز خطابه الانتخابيه والاجتماعي
والاقتصادي الذي نجح فيه الى حد كبير
بنيل ثقه الاتراك بطبيعه الحال كل جدار
اوغلو لن ينسى ورقته الرابحه والتي عززت
طبعا حضوره وصوتت لصالحه خلال مختلف
المحطات الانتخابيه واعطته هذه المره 20%
من الاصوات الناخبه هذه الورقه هي الاكراد
طبعا
والاعاده بالانتخابات التركيه العشرون من
مايو يبدا التصويت في بوابات الجمارك
الحدوديه وبالخارج الرابع والعشرون من
مايو تبدا خطابات دعايه للمرشحين وتنتهي
في السابع والعشرين من الشهر نفسه المجلس
الاعلى للانتخابات حدد الثامن والعشرين من
مايو يوم للاقتراع داخل البلاد الاول من
يونيو تعلن نتيجه نهائيه عبر الجريده
الرسميه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من اسطنبول فاقبلت
المحلل السياسي سابدا معك استاذ من ما
سمعناه بموضوع الانقسام الحاصل وكيفيه جذب
القواعد الباقيه للجوله الثانيه اليوم
سنان اوغان معروف بانه من المحافظين وبانه
يعني شرط الاساسي هو عدم دعم الاكراد
والذين يعتبرهم بانهم يهددون الامن القومي
لتركيا وبالتالي هل يمكن القول بان هذه
الاصوات ستصب لصالح اردوغان في جوله
الاعاده
هو منشق عن طبعا الحزب الحركه القوميه
التورانيه
فبالتالي لديه كراهيه كبيره جدا ايذاء
الاتراك اكراد هذه معروفه يعني ليس فقط
اذا كل الاجانب خسيسا من اللاجئين
السوريين وافغانيين لذلك
صحيح ايضا اننا بما انه منشاق عن حزب
الحركه القوميه فاعتقد انه يعني منطقيه
انه لا انه لن يتعامل مع هذه هذا الحزب
وكان له ايضا انتقادات شديده الشديده
اللهجه جدا يعني حتى ممكن ان نقول يعني
معاركه كلاميه بين
السينالوجان وبين السيد رجب طيب اردو ولكن
يعني انا بعرفه كصحفي يعني وهو ايضا من
بلدي
[موسيقى]
فحسب معلومات
لديه ولكن غير مؤكده كصحفي
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه السيد رجب طيب اردوغان انه توصل
معه يعني
واتفق معه
طبعا هو يسود هو وانصاره يصوتون لصالح
السيد
يمكن سيد رجب طيب سيحصل على تقريبا اربعه
وخمسون بالمئه او خمسه وخمسين بالمئه
وبالتالي سوف يتجاوز عتبه عتبه الجوله
الثانيه
ولكن هذا احتمال لاني
الاكراد هنا ورقه الاكراد التي اتكل عليها
التحالف تحالف المعارضه بالجوله الاولى
كيف ممكن ان تغير بنتائج بالجوله الثانيه
خصوصا اننا كنا نتحدث حتى بالجوله الاولى
عن ان الاكراد لن يصب يعني جميع الاصوات
للمعار ضه هناك جزء منهم صب لصالح يعني
حزب العداله والتنميه وحتى الساعه ليس
هناك من ارقام تقريبيه كيف صبت هذه
الاصوات
يعني طبعا بالنسبه للسنان مره اخرى اعود
يعني هناك في حزب الله كردي فبما انه يكره
الاكراد لماذا لم يشترط حتى الان لم يشترط
يعني على يعني عدم عدم التحالف او عدم
الارتباط
سلطه الحاليه بحزب الله الكردي هذه النقطه
مهمه جدا ومتناقضه جدا هذه النقطه نقطه
ثانيه يعني في الحقيقه انه الافراد في
مناطق طبعا كرديه
سواء صوت صوت يعني بنسبه عاليه جدا يعني
اكثر من 50% 60% سبعين بالمئه في مناطق
يعني مختلفه من
مناطق الكرديه لصالح لصالح
المعارضه
رجب طيب ولكن في هناك معروف ان هناك امن
معارك داريه في هذه المناطق الكرديه طبعا
هناك في قوه الجيش في قوه في قوه خلينا
نقول حراس الحدود وما الى ذلك يعني هذه
كلهم العناصر الدوله يعني هذا جزء من دوله
يعني
قد تكون قد تكون هناك قد يكون هناك
تزويرات في التلاعب بالاصوات يعني قد يعني
قبل ذلك قبل قبل قبل الانتخابات قبل هذه
يعني الحضور الكردي الى جانب طبعا الازمه
الاقتصاديه عزز حصوص حظوظ المعارضه
بالجوله الاولى ولكن هذا لا يعني تعزيز
حظوظه بالجوله الثانيه ابقى معنا استاذ لو
سمحت
مشاهدينا قال هنا جونكر بالمتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي في البيت الابيض ان
امريكا تتابع عن كسب الانتخابات التركيه
واضاف بان الرئيس جو بايدن يتطلع للعمل مع
الفائز في الانتخابات ايا كان
اعود اليك استاذ فائق يعني ملفت التصريح
الامريكي اليوم بخدام هذه الانتخابات التي
قيل عنها الكثير من دعم غربي وامريكي
لجانب المعارضه اليوم يعني كان هناك تصريح
كيربي وايضا قبله تصريح الرئيس الامريكي
الذي قال سنتعامل مع من ما كان الفائز
والمنطقه فيها الكثير من المشاكل ولا
تحتمل اكثر كيف تنظر لهذه التصريحات
القول يعني على ان امريكا كل من امريكا
لولايه المتحده ودول اتعادل الاوروبي سوف
تدعم يعني معارضه منذ الزمان يعني فهذه
اسطوره خلينا كل الاسطوره يعني هذه
استهلاكاتها المحليه فاديه جدا نحن نعرف
دول الكبرى يعني سميت الالمانيا وفرنسا
وولايات المتحده وحتى بريطانيا هي يعني
تقف على مصلحتها يعني اذا مصلحتها مع هذا
الرجل سوف يعني تصالح او تتعاون مع هذا
الرجل اذا مصلحتها ماذا ذلك الرجل سوف
تتعلق ايضا من اعراف الدولية ولكن هناك
خوف هنا بهذه النقطه بانه اصبح يعني
اردوغان اتحدث اقرب بكثير للاوراسيين مما
هو للحلف الغربي وهذا يخيف طبعا الولايات
المتحده وكل الاتحاد الاوروبي شكرا لك
استاذ فاق بولوت انتهى الوقت عذرا على
المقاطعه حدثتنا من اسطنبول
لاول مره شارك سوريون حاصلون على الجنسيه
التركيه في الانتخابات التركيه وعلى
الجانب الاخر من الحدود يترقب السوريون
نتائج الانتخابات وما ستحمله طبعا من
انعكاسات على المنطقه
هنا لا صوت يعلو على صوت ناخب تجربه لم
يعتد عليها محمد من قبل محمد السوري الذي
سقطت عنه صفه اللاجئ وبات اليوم مواطنا
تركيا مارس حقوقه الانتخابيه واختار من
بين مرشحي الرئاسه من تمكن من اقناعه
بتنفيذ مصالحه ومتطلباته تجربه يعني جديره
بالاهتمام
مهمه بالنسبه الي يعني تكاد تكون يعني حل
بسيط لكل مشاكلنا المعقده ان يلجا الفرقاء
او من يريد يعني ان يدير البلد او الشخص
او الحزب الذي يرى في نفسه الاهليه لقياده
هذا يتقدم الى الناس يشرح خطته ويشرح
برامجه للناس والناس بكل بساطه وسلاسه
ممكن يعني تدلي بصوتها بحيث يعني ينال
الرضا
ينال القبول ينال الشرعيه من الناس وصلت
اعداد السوريين الحاصلين على الجنسيه
التركيه
230 الفا بينهم 130 الفا يحق لهم ان
يصوتوا في هذه الانتخابات التي يشاركون
فيها بعيدا عن موطنهم الاصلي
يترقب السوريون على هذا الجانب من الحدود
نتائج المعركه الانتخابيه التركيه وكيف
ستنعكس على حالهم وحياتهم
تتاثر مناطق شمال غربي سوريا وخاصه منطقتي
الابيض وراس العين بالنظام السياسي التركي
واي تغييرات قد تشهدها فيعيش في المنطقه
ما يقارب من اربعه ملايين ونصف المليون
نسمه غالبيتهم يحتاجون للمساعده وتعتبر
المعابر الحدوديه مع تركيا الشريان الوحيد
لهم كما تتاثر المنطقه اقتصاديا فالتعامل
هنا بالليره التركيه والحركه التجاريه
مرتبطه بالمعابر ايضا والاهم هو الجانب
العسكري والسياسي باعتبار تركيا وسياستها
مع الملف السوري عاملا اساسيا لتحديد
مستقبل المنطقه وخارطه السيطره اليوم حديث
الشارع في المناطق هون عم تتحدث عن
انتخابات التركيه ونتائج الانتخابات
التركيه اكيد في ارتباط وثيق بين انتخابات
تركيا ومصير هذه المناطق وخاصه التجاري او
الصعيد الانساني يرى البعض ان حاله الترقب
هذه لن تنتهي باعلان نتائج الانتخابات
التركيه بل ستستمر حتى تحديد النظام
السياسي التركي وطريقه تعاطيه مع الملف
السوري محمد الاشقر العربيه الحدود
السوريه التركيه
مستمره
الاردن يؤكد على سلامه بعثه الدبلوماسيه
بالسودان بعد تعرض سفارته بالخرطوم
للاعتداء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد شهر كامل من الصراع
والاقتصاد العسكري في السودان والاوضاع
الانسانيه من سيء الى اسوا لجنه دوليه
للصليب الاحمر قالت ان المرافق الصحيه في
السودان على وشك الانهيار علاجنا اضافت
ايضا وحذرت من ان مرافق الرعايه الصحيه في
السودان تعاني من اسابيع من نقص الامدادات
والعلاج مشيره الى توقف اكثر من 70% من
المستشفيات عن العمل بدوره اتهم قطاع
النفط السودانيه الدعم السريع بمنع توزيع
المشتقات النفطيه بعد سيطرته على مصفاه
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا المياه مقطوعه وانت وفرت فهي ملوثه
واحياء سكنيه تحولت الى منطقه اشباح موحشه
يخيم عليها الخراب والموت هذا مشاهدينا
بعض ما تواجهه مدينه الخرطوم بحري التي
يقطنها مليونان نسمه تقريبا بعد شهر من
الاقتتال العسكري بين طرفي النزاع الكارثه
في المدينه كبيره جدا حتى دفن الموتى اصبح
مهمه عسيره وشاقه وهنا تخوف كبير من
انتشار طبعا الامراض والاوبئه بعد تحلل
هذه الجثث في الطرقات المدينه التي تمثل
الضلع الثالث للعاصمه المثلثه تواجه ايضا
شحف الوقود وانقطاع الكهرباء والاتصالات
بعدما تاثرت شبكات الاتصال وابراج
التقنيات لانقطاع التيار الكهربائي جراء
طبعا القصف المتبادل والعشوائي بين طرفي
الصراع هذا المشهد مشاهدينا حول
الخرطوم بحري الى منطقه كوارث خاصه بعد
تدهور الاوضاع الامنيه وانتشار عصابات
السلب والسرقه هذا كان ميدانيا اما سياسيا
جمد رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقاليه عبد
الفتاح البرهان حسابات قوات الدعم السريع
وشركاتها في جميع البنوك في السودان
وفروعها في الخارج
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
لايف مباشر
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الاردنيه تعرض مبنى
السفاره الاردنيه في الخرطوم لاقتحام
وتخريب واعربت الخارجيه عن ادانتها
واستنكارها للاعتداء ولاعمال العنف
والتخريب كافه خاصه تلك التي تستهدف
المباني الدبلوماسيه وتنتهك السياده
لنقل الصوره من على الارض ينضم الينا
مشاهدينا من الخرطوم الصحافه عمار ابو
شيبه عمار كيف هي الصوره من هناك
الاشتباكات الوضع الامني
والصوره على الارض لو سمحت
[موسيقى]
نعم اهلا بك واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرامة
الصوره على الارض تبدو الان في حاله هدوء
حذر في عدد كبير جدا من احياء العاصمه
الخرطوم منذ صباح الباكر كانت هنالك عدد
من المناطق التي تعرضت للقصف الجوي من قبل
الطيران التابع للجيش السوداني خاصه
بمنطقه شرق النيل ومستشفى شرق النيل
واصدرت فيها قوات الدعم السريع بيانا حيث
افادت فيه بانها ربما يعني من خلال الرصد
الميداني لديها اشارت الى ان هذا القصف
الذي من خلاله نفذ الطيران الحربي للجيش
السوداني ادى الى عدد من الوفيات وعدد من
المناطق خاصه المجاوره للمستشفى وقوات
الجيش السوداني في الجانب الاخر اردت
ببيان واكدت من خلالها انها رصدت عدد من
الاليات المراه العسكريه وعدد من ربما
تناكر الوقود قامت بقصفها في تلك المنطقه
الوضع في عدد من الاحياء ايضا كذلك الخاصه
مدينه ام درمان ووسط العاصمه الخرطومي
يشير بشكل واضح على ان الهدوء يسيطر على
الموقف بشكل واضح وكبير ولكن قبل لحظات
كنا نستمع ايضا الى طائرات الاستطلاع تحلق
بكثافه في عدد من الاحياء ولا وجود
للطائرات المقاتله الحربيه في هذه اللحظات
الهدوء بشكل واضح يبدو حذرا من خلال هذه
السنه ماذا عنا المساعدات الانسانيه عمار
خصوصا انها كانت يعني في صلب الجوله
الاولى من المحادثات بين الطرفين هل تم
ادخال اي منها
نعم الحديث عن المساعدات الانسانيه في هذا
التوقيت يبدو بائنا وواضح وفيها عدد من
الاشارات باعتبارنا الاتفاق اتفاق المبادئ
في اعلان جده ربما يعني من خلاله تم
الحديث عن هذه النقطه بشكل واضح وكبير
وربما ننتظر عدد من الايام وعدد من
الساعات حتى يتبلور هذا الاتفاق الاتفاق
وقف اطلاق النار بشكل واضح حتى من خلاله
تتم عمليه ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه خاصه
الى وسط العاصمه الخرطوم عدد من المدن
الخاصه مدينه
البورسودان وولايه البحر الاحمر دخلت
اليها عدد من المساعدات من عدد من الدول
تبقى الوصول الى مدينه الخرطوم وربما
ولايه الجزيره ومدينه تتجهز بشكل واضح
وكبير لدخول هذه المساعدات الانسانيه بحكم
القرب الولايه من ولايه الخرطوم ايضا كذلك
الحديث عن المساعدات الانسانيه في هذا
التوقيت خاصه مع دخول الازمه الى شهر
الثاني
[موسيقى]
استقبل وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان نظيرته الالمانيه في جده
واعربه
السفيره او وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه عن
شكر وتقدير بلادها لما قامت به المملكه من
عمليات اجلاء لرعايه المانيا من السودان
منوهه بالكفاءه العاليه للجهات السعوديه
في نجاح هذه العمليات وعقد الجانبان جلسه
مباحثات رسميه تطرقت لصبل تعزيز جهود
البلدين في ارساء دعائم السلام بالمنطقه
والعالم
دعا وزير الاقتصاد والتجاره الخارجيه
السوريه محمد سامر الخليل خلال اجتماع
للمجلس الاقتصادي والاجتماعي التحضيري
للقمه العربيه التي تستضيفها السعوديه
الدول العربيه الى الاستثمار في سوريا
وقال الوزير السوري في كلمه القاها امام
الجلسه الافتتاحيه للمؤتمر في جده ان
بلاده تدعو الى المشاركه في الاستثمار في
سوريا حيث توجد فرص مهمه وافاق واعده على
حد تعبيره كما شكر الخليل في خطابه الدول
العربيه على ارسال مساعدات الى سوريا في
اعقاب الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا في
فبراير الماضيه
[موسيقى]
غياب مثير للجدل بعد انتشار شائعات عن
تدهور صحه لوكاشينكو وتداول انباء عن
معاناته من مرض خطير دعت المعارضه
البيلاروسيه في المنفى الشعبي للاستعداد
للتغيير السياسي
بالنسبه لنا هذا يعني شيئا واحدا علينا ان
نتحضر جيدا لاي سيناريو من اجل تحويل
بيلاروسيا لطريق الديمقراطيه ومنع روسيا
من التدخل
الرئيس البيلاروسي لم يظهر للعلن خلال
الايام سته الماضيه وكان اخر ظهور له في
موسكو للمشاركه في الاحتفالات بيوم النصر
السوفيتي على النازيين
لكنه غاب عن الغداء الذين نظمه حليفه
بوتين ولم يعلق المسؤولون حتى الان على
غيابه عن الحياه العامه
التسع مستمرات مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
شراكه مرتقبه بين ايلون ماسك وسامسونج
لتصنيع الرقائق
[موسيقى]
بعد اشهر طويله من بدء القتال في المنطقه
اوكرانيا تعلن عن اول نجاح لهجومها المضاد
في محيط مدينه بخموت التي تشهد اطول واعنف
معركه في اطار الهجوم الروسي اذا هنا
الهجوم المضاد الذي تحدثت عنه اوكرانيا
فبحسب قائد الجيش الاوكراني انكاز استطاعت
السيطره على عشره مناطق بضواحي مركز
المدينه واستطاعت ان تطرد القوات الروسيه
من هذه المنطقه وبحسب ما هو معلوم
مشاهدينا في ان الهجوم المضاد الذين نتحدث
عنه بدا من جهه الشمال وبالتالي من ليمان
وايضا من منطقتين كما هو معلوم حتى الساعه
من مارينكا ومن اذا هذه الجهات كلها
تستخدمها اليوم القوات الاوكرانيه لمحاوله
استعاده السيطره على بخموت التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الروسيه على حوالي 95% من
هذه المدينه التي دمرت بالكامل وطبعا ليس
فقط القوات الروسيه الموجوده هنا والتي
تقاتل في هذه المنطقه منذ فتره طويله
وانما هي وايضا قوات فاجنر الروسيه التي
تعتبر الخط الامامي وخط الهجوم الاساس
بهذه المعركه هنا تعويل اوكراني بالهجوم
المضاد على التدريب الذي قامت به القوات
الاوكرانيه بالفتره الماضيه اتحدث عن سته
اشهر قامت خلالها القوات الاوكرانيه
بتدريب قواتها على نمط مختلف من القتال
برومانيا بالمانيا والمناطق المجاوره لحلف
الناتو هناك تعويل ايضا على الاسلحه
الغربيه التي ستستخدمها اوكرانيا بالفتره
المقبله وبالفتره اللاحقه لاستخدامه بهذا
الهجوم المضاد وطبعا على الروح المعنويه
التي تعول عليها بشكل كبير والتي استفادت
منها بالهجوم المضاد
بالفتره الماضيه والتي قامت به منذ سته
اشهر واليوم هناك تعويل اساسي وتقول بان
القوات الروسيه ليس لديها هذه الروح
المعنويه
صواريخه ستورم شادو من نوع جو ارض بعيده
المدى مداها اكثر من 250 كيلومترا مقارنه
بصواريخ هاي مارس التي زودتها بها
الولايات المتحده بمدن لا يتجاوز 80 كيلو
مترا يتم اطلاق الصواريخ من الطائرات ما
يعني ان الطيارين الاوكرانيين سيكونون
قادرين على البقاء بعيدا عن الخطوط
الاماميه هذا وقد زودت بريطانيا اوكرانيا
مسبقا بمعدات عسكريه اخرى منها اربع عشره
دبابه تشالنجر اثنان في يناير الماضي
وطائرات بدون طيار من نوع مالويتي 150
القادره على التحليق لسته وثلاثين دقيقه
ويتم التحكم فيها من قبل جندي عبر حاسوب
صخر رئيس مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه من تقرير
صحفيات واشنطن بوسط الامريكيه افاد بانه
يتعاون مع اوكرانيا وعرض عليها معلومات
حول مواقع القوات الروسيه وقال انها محطه
تقارير مضحكه وقدر رئيس فاجنر ان يكون
افراد من النخبه الروسيه وراء هذه
الاتهامات مشيرا الى انهم يلقون عليه
باللائمه فيما وصف الناطق باسم الكريم
المعلومات التي نشرتها واشنطن بوست بانها
اخبار مضلله
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من كياف حذيفه عادل
مراسل العربيه حذيفه مع يعني بدء الحديث
عن استعاده بعض المناطق في مخمود تحديدا
الهدف الاساسي بالفتره الماضيه هو فصل
الدومباس عن شبه جزيره القرن ما هي خارطه
العمليات التي بداتها القوات الاوكرانيه
مساء الخير الان ينظر الى الهجوم المضاده
الذي تقوده كيف في مدينه باقمو تحديدا الى
انه الهجوم المضاد هجوم مضاد غير معلن من
قبل السلطات الاوكرانيه الذي انتظره
الجميع الان
الجيش الاوكراني استطاع في ثلاثه ايام فقط
وطبعا هذا التقدم لثلاثه ايام على التوالي
ولكن تم الاعلان عنه اليوم عن حجم التقدم
الذي حققه الجيش الاوكراني الجيش
الاوكراني استطاع ان يستعيد عشره مواقع
وهذا رقم كبير بالنسبه للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وبالنسبه لتمركز القوات بشكل
كثيف من قبل الاتحاد الروسي وقوات فاجنر
في مدينه باقمت استطاع ان يستعيد عشره
مواقع استطاع ان يستعيد 17 كيلومترا مربعا
يعني في العاده حتى في اشد انواع الهجوم
التي كان يقودها الاتحاد الروسي كان يكسب
في اليوم 200 متر 300 متر وما شابه ذلك
وكذلك القوات الاوكرانيه عندما تقود هج
الدفاع الجويه الان هنالك اسلحه هجوميه
هذه الصواريخ وكذلك المسيرات الهجوميه
التي
تتحدث عن الاسلحه نوعيه تصل الى قواعد
الموجوده على البحر الاسود وبالتالي عن
مرحله مختلفه جدا حذيفه انتهى الوقت شكرا
لك على هذه الرساله من كاف مراسل العربيه
حذيفه
استبعد رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ريجيسوناك
وجود خطط لارسال مقاتلات لاوكرانيا خصوصا
انها تفضل استخدام مقاتلات امريكيه اف 16
واكد صنعك خلال لقائه مع بريطانيا ستكون
من ضمن تحالف الدول التي ستدرب
الاوكرانيين على استخدام الطائرات الحربيه
قريبا بدوره اكد الرئيس الاوكراني انه
تلقى وعودا بالحصول على صواريخ
هجوميه كاشفا عن حصيله كبيره من المساعدات
العسكريه الاوروبيه خلال جولته الاخيره
حزمه عسكريه جديده ستسلمها لندن الى
القوات الاوكرانيه للدفاع عن اراضيها ضد
روسيا وطرد عناصرها من المناطق التي
احتلتها منذ بدء موسكو حمله العسكريه
العام الماضي رساله بريطانيه حملت طمانه
الشعب الاوكراني والرئيس الاوكراني الذي
حل ضيفا في زياره خاطفه لبيت ريسوسونك
الريفي من جهه وتحذيرا لموسكو من جهه اخرى
من المهم ان يعرف الكريم اننا سنستمر في
دعم اوكرانيا على المدى الطويل سنظل
صامدين في تقديم المساعده لاوكرانيا ليس
فقط الان لاستعاده اراضيها الشرعيه ولكن
ايضا لضمان ان اوكرانيا لديها وسيله
للدفاع عن نفسها
مئات صواريخ والانظمه الدفاعيه الجويه بما
فيها طائرات بدون طيار بعيده المدى
ستوفرها الحكومه البريطانيه لاوكرانيا
وتراها لندن ضروريه في مقاومه كياف حربا
فظيعه فرضتها موسكو على
الاوكرانيينسكي ممتن للدعم البريطاني
المتواصل لبلده حتى قبل بدايه الحمله
العسكريه لكنه يضغط للحصول على الطائرات
حربيه
تحدثنا اليوم عن تزويدنا بمقاتلات والامر
مهم جدا لاننا لا نتحكم في اجواءنا وهذا
معروف كوننا شركاء حقيقيين يعرف كل تفاصيل
ما يجري في ساحه المعركه ونريد انشاء
تحالف للحصول على الطائرات الحربيه وانا
متفائل جدا في هذا الخصوص لان هناك قرارات
مهمه ستتخذ قريبا
فيما المناقشات مستمره اكد سوناك ان بلاده
ستكون جزءا من تحالف دوليا لتقديم الدعم
الذي يطالب به زيلينسكي اجتماع الزعيمين
ياتي بعد ان وافقت الحكومه البريطانيه
الاسبوع الماضي على ارسال صواريخ بعيده
المدى لاول مره الى جانب الدعم العسكري
بقيمه مليارين وثلاثه مليون جنيه تعاهدت
به لندن العام الماضي
لا توجد خطط لارسال طائرات حربيه بريطانيه
لاوكرانيا لكن وزاره الدفاع اكدت انها
ستدرب الطيارين اوكرانيين على طائرات اف
16 التي لا تستخدم في سلاح الجو الملكي
والحزمه العسكريه الجديده تاكيد على
مواصله وقوف بريطانيا مع الشعب الاوكراني
وحمايه اراضيه مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
[موسيقى]
وللمره الثانيه خلال اقل من اسبوع مثل
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان امام
القضاء مجدد مجددا للرد على الاتهامات
الموجهه اليه بعد اعتقاله واحتجازه
الاسبوع الماضي بشان التخطيط لاعمال العنف
التي اعاقبت توقيفه ومثوله خان امام محكمه
في لاهور للرد على الاتهامات الموجهه اليه
بالتخطيط لاعمال العنف التي اعقبت توقيفه
بحسب احد محاميها
هذا وقد توافد الاف المحتاجين
الباكستانيين وشقوا طريقهم نحو مقر
المحكمه العليا في اسلام اباد مطالبين
باستقاله رئيس المحكمه لقراره الافراج عن
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان فيما ندد
مؤتمر لكبار قاده الجيش بهجمات انصار خان
على منشات عسكريه وتعاهدوا بمعاقبه كل من
لهم علاقه بالعنف وفقا للقوانين المدنيه
والعسكريه
من اسلام ابد ينضم الينا عبد الرحمن
المزيني مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن يعني
كيف هي الصوره من هناك خصوصا وسط هذا
التجاذب السياسي والشعب الموجود
نعم بالفعل اجتماع قاده خيالق الجيش
الباكستاني والبيان الصادر له
ارسل رساله واضحه يمكن او يرى فيها
المراقبون بان ما كان يوصف بزواج المصلحه
بين المؤسسه العسكريه
وعمران خان قد انتهى ربما الى غير رجعه
وان الايام المقبله ستكون ايام صعبه
لامران خان الذي عليه ان يقف امام خيارات
كلها صعبه ربما
افضلها هو
التنحي
جزئيا او
لعده سنوات ربما عن العمل السياسي واتاحه
الفرصه لحزبه لمواصله العمل السياسي دون
ان يكون هو على راس الحزب وربما اقصاها
ربما السجن في
ربما الاتهامات التي سوف توجه له
باساره الفوضى والعنف البيان الصادر عن
الجيش الباكستاني لم يسمي عمران خان او
حزب الانصاف
بالاسم لكن اكد انه لديه من الادله
الكافيه التي تدين مثيري الشغب ومن يقف
ورائهم قال انه كانت هناك محاوله لاستفزاز
القوات المسلحه وجرها الى هذه الازمه
السياسيه ولكن قوات الامن اكدت
قامت باقصى درجات ضبط النفس لكن الجيش في
المقابل قال انه لن يتهاون مره اخرى مع اي
محاولاته النيل من المؤسسه العسكريه او
محاوله تقسيمها وقال ان بعض الاحزاب
السياسيه او القوى السياسيه
حاولت استفزاز الجيش من اجل مصالح
سياسيه وقال بانه سوف يتم معاقبه هؤلاء
الجناه والمحرضين ومثيري
التي اعقبت اعتقال رئيس وزراء السابق
عمران خان وفق القوانين الباكستانيه
المختلفه ومن بينها القانون الخاص بالجيش
الباكستاني اي المحاكمه العسكريه في
المقابل او في موازاه ذلك ايضا البرلمان
الباكستاني اصدر قرار ندد به بالهجمات
التي تعرضت لها المؤسسات الحكوميه والعامه
لا سيما مرافق الجيش ونصب التذكاريه
للشهداء ومنزل مؤسس باكستان في مدينه
لاهور وقالت بان الجناه الذين يثقون وراء
هذه هذه الاعمال وهذه
نتحدث عنه اما السجن واما التنحي هو مسار
معروف يعني بتاريخ الرؤساء الوزراء
الباكستانيين شكرا لك عبد الرحمن المزيني
مراسل العربيه حدثتنا من اسلام اباد
[موسيقى]
كشفت شركه سامسونج ان رئيسها التقى مع
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تسلا ايلون ماسك
وعقد الاجتماع مع ماسك في مركز ابحاث
اشباه الموصلات التابع لشركه سامسونج في
وادي السيليكون فالي بولايه كاليفورنيا في
اشاره الى شراكه محتمله بين شركه تصنيع
الرقائق الرائده في العالم وعملاق صناعه
السيارات الكهربائيه تسلا
[موسيقى]
اجلت فرق الانقاذ نحو الف شخص حصروا بسبب
مياه البحر التي بلغ عمقها اكثر من ثلاثه
امتار على طول الساحل الغربي باحدى ولايات
ميانمار بعد اعصار قوي ادى لمقتل سته
اشخاص واصابه المئات ووقوع اضرار وقطع
الاتصالات
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
قبل جوله الاعاده باسبوعين وبورقتي
الاكراد واللاجئين سنان اوغان يرسل شروط
دعمه لاردوغان او كلش
قوه او قطاع النفط في السودان يؤكد سيطره
قوات الدعم السريعه على مواصفات الخرطوم
ويتهمها بتعطيل التوزيع
الاوروبيه بحصيله مساعدات ضخمه بينها
صواريخ ودبابات ومسيرات هجوميه
بعد اخراجه عن عمران خان انصار الحكومه
الباكستانيه يطالبون باستقاله رئيس
المحكمه العليا
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360 مع
زميله راويه راويه اضافه الى الانتخابات
التركيه طبعا ومتابعه نتائجها ماذا لديك
الليله طبعا السيناريوهات جوله الاعاده
وايضا توقعات وتحذيرات من انهيار القطاع
الصحي في السودان تفضل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات